- This is my Whole Lotta Woman Hour,
and in honor of International Women's Day,
we're checking in with
some of the gifted girls
I've paired with successful
women, who inspired them.
A few weeks ago, I surprised
a 12 year old fashionista
with Baby Phat founder,
Kimora Lee Simmons.
Check it out.
(Electronic whooshing)
How did you get into designing clothes?
- When I was eight,
me and my mom were cleaning out my closet.
I was like, mom, I don't
wanna give away my clothes,
I wanna upcycle them.
So she's like, what's upcycling?
(Audience laughs)
So, I told her what it was,
and she enrolled me in
private sewing lessons.
- But I do have a surprise for Skylar,
the woman behind Baby Phat
and so many other successful businesses,
(audience gasps)
Kimora Lee Simmons, come on out!
(upbeat rock music)
- I brought you a little something here.
And we just wanna tell you
how proud we are of you.
And if you would be willing,
I would like to accept you under my wing,
(Audience gasps)
and offer you a mentorship.
(Audience screams and claps)
- What do you think?
(Kimora laughs)
- Oh.
- Yeah!
(audience cheers and claps)
Please welcome Kimora Lee Simmons, y'all.
(upbeat rock music)
(audience cheers and claps)
- Hi, how are you?
- Nice to see you.
(Applause)
- I feel like I didn't mean to do this
but I invited like two beautiful models
to sit next to for an hour.
It's fine, I feel great about myself.
So have you all meet before?
- Yes
- We have
- We kind of go way back in the 90s
in New York, I think.
- [Kelly] Wow
- I can tell you all those stories
- [Kelly] How very TLC I like it
- On another show for Woman's day
(Laughter)
- Well Kimora so since the show
have you been able to
hang out with Skylar?
or do anything with Skylar?
- Of course yes.
So she came to New York.
We brought her to New York and um
she came into our studio or
"atelier Casa de Kimora."
That's not really what's it called
it's our Baby Phat head quarter
- I want you to call it that
it sounds fancy.
- And she, we put her straight to work
she had sketches, we've
lectured, we've mentored,
we've reviewed all her things,
we've brought some things to life
she went all over the city.
- [Kelly] Well New York is awesome
she checked out fabric houses, yeah.
- I would walk into those places
though and be overwhelmed,
and y'all walk in and get inspired
I'd be like there's so much fabric!
(laughter)
like, I mean like I do that like
a Joanne just making quilts.
(laughter)
So a few weeks ago Kimora offered
to mentor an extremely
talented twelve year-old
fashionista, let's see what happened
when they met up in New York.
(Upbeat music)
- Today is going to be a really big day
because I'm taking my first step
to being a real fashion designer.
- Hi!
- Welcome to Casa de Kimora,
I'll show you around a little bit.
Skylar has a lot of passion for design
and as a business woman and
entrepreneur and a mother,
it's very important for
me to work and empower
the dreams of young designers
and young women everywhere.
So why don't you come into my office
and we can chit-chat about some things
and I can see what
you've brought me today.
- I cannot wait to have a go
at my fashion ideas with her.
I'm really excited to show her my designs
and I'm super excited to see
what she says about it.
Oh, here are some of my designs,
this one is just like
a opposite of a dress
with like a wrap-around type skirt.
This one is like a balloon
sleeve with like a curve.
- That's really cute.
I'm gonna have to wear that.
(Skylar laughs)
Her designs and her sketches
are exciting and vibrant and fun
and it shows a little
bit of her personality.
- This one is,
I actually sketched this one last night.
I was little bit nervous
to see what she had to say,
but you have to have tough skin
even when they say that
they're not gonna use your designs.
(Suspenseful Music)
- Okay I see a lot of things here
I feel like we should work with.
I definitely think we should take these
back to the design team,
and then we could crank
some of these thing out.
All the sketches are really great,
but the red stands out to me a lot
because you can dress
it up or dress it down,
you can put it with a blazer.
So we can absolutely help her
create that top and that pants.
This is the team
this is Caesar, Megan and Karen.
This is my little Skylar.
- When I walked in today I did not think
that we would actually be
able to make an outfit,
and I think this is just gonna be amazing.
- So you matching this over that,
and your belting.
- Yeah like that.
- Boom! We're going, we're going.
So this is where it's all starts.
- Before this I really only
just had me working on all of my outfits.
- So it starts with your sketch,
and now that you've chosen a fabric,
we'll create a pattern then we'll work it
and check in with the measurements,
and things along the way.
- Yes, and then start assembling them.
It's like building a house.
- When you've been in the
business as long as I have,
you look more towards creating a legacy.
So I think it when you can look back
and someone says
you know you helped me
you helped me create,
you helped me design,
you helped me realize my vision.
That is how I measure success.
And next time we see
you this will be done.
- Cool!
I definitely won't forget this day,
because I think that one day
I'll be a big designer
and see that this is
where it all like began.
(audience applauds)
- All right so that is,
I just love seeing a
young woman like that bold
and that like just projected,
she said, "I will be."
Like she didn't say, "I want to be",
she said, "I will be a big designer."
And I'm like projecting
that is everything.
- Absolutely.
- Wow!
- Speak it!
- Yeah, you have to.
So what's the most important thing
that you felt like you
wanted to teach Skylar?
- I wanted her to know,
first of all I wanted her to understand
which she did touch on rejection.
You may go places,
I make it all the time,
I make stuff all the time
and all the magazines
that everybody write it,
they say I hate it.
- Mm hmm.
- Or they say I love it.
You have to be able to
like roll with the punches.
Like she said it, have a thick skin
so I wanted her to understand that.
But beyond that, I wanted
her to understand that
the sky is the limit.
That you can be a girl boss,
you can be a woman designer.
(Crowd applause.)
You can be a mom and a businesswoman.
You can be you know who you are,
we are who we are, and we can get it done.
So there's no labels
or titles or boundaries
that should hold us back
- [Kelly] Yeah no limits
- No limits
- Yeah.
So Kimora's team was able to
put together Skylar's design
and she's here to show it off.
Come on out!
(Upbeat music)
- So cute
(Cheering)
- Come on over!
You look so good!
- Thank you.
- Oh my gosh!
You did this!
Look at that team work!
Come on over!
- Wow, hi!
- Sit down with us.
- How are you?
That's Liv.
- Hey nice to meet you.
Hello how are you?
You look beautiful.
- Thank you
- And I'm just saying
you had your arms behind your back,
I'll be like girl when you look that good.
Just walk with those arms proud.
(All laughing)
I'm like so sway sway.
you look so cute, the hair everything,
the whole look is nice.
Was this exciting?
What was your favorite part?
- So I mean I love New
York but my favorite part
was definitely getting to
see like how the team works.
And like when she comes
in, like her presence
everybody is just like oh let me,
like they're ready to help her.
(Audience laughs)
- That's a girl boss! Hey!
- And you can just tell
that everybody like
loves working with her.
- That's amazing,
hey that does say a lot about people, yes.
- I really just wanted to thank you
for having like,
you have like a whole bunch of jobs,
you have kids,
I just want to thank you for like,
you know, having me.
You're hugging me.
- You're welcome.
You look amazing.
- Thank you.
- This came out good.
You did this under the gun.
- That's amazing like would you...
this is adorable!
- The back details are amaze--
- I know the back did y'all see it?
Stand up, let's show them that back again.
Look how cute that is.
(Applause)
- [Kelly] So cute.
- Amazing.
- It's cute.
- I can see you in that,
you're already wearing
like a red kinda orange.
- [Liv] Yes.
- So Kimora you have one more surprise
for everyone though right?
- Yes so when Skylar brought in her design
she has like every good
designer has a sketch book
and I being me I'm like, "I want that
and we have to make that
and we have to do that."
So we did this outfit for her.
- Yeah.
- She created it, sketched
it, we assembled it,
manufactured it if you would,
and made it come to life.
And then I have on
another one of her designs
from her sketch book.
- This is you?
Wait stand up for us!
(Applause)
- [Kelly] Look it's amazing
- [Skylar] Thank you
- [Kelly] Look at that!
- Now I didn't make the
sleeve as voluminous
cause mama is already a little voluminous.
I took it down--
(Laughter)
A little point tuck at the top.
But yeah this is hers.
- That's almost like a cool
red carpet version too.
The voluminous?
- These are our Skylar
Baby Phat colabarations.
- [Kelly] That is amazing!
- We're on our way,
we're working for you.
(Laughter)
- Are you loving it?
Did you just love being in the building?
Everything just soaking it all in?
- Yeah it was... I learned a lot.
- That's so cool!
That is so cool, what a blessing?